الى الوضع في سوريا في جنديرس وعفرين بريف
حلب اكد مواطنونا حاجتهم الماسه للمساعدات
الخيمه اليوم بشكل يعني ضروري جدا يعني
اليوم الاطفال نحن بنتحمل الورد ما في
مشكله نحن نبرك تحت هيك ما في اي مشكله بس
اطفال نساء
المصاب اللي طالعناه من تحت التراب يعني
ردود كذا هلق نزلت انا اولادي على المشفى
جسمه كله ازرق
والله اولادي كلهم مرضان يفوتوا شو فيهم
انا صارلي جمعه من وقت الهيكل يا لطيف صار
فينا
مرضانين من المشفى عندي أنا شهيد الحمد
لله
وضعنا كتير تعبان
وينه وين مساعدتك
لسه بالدقيق ما عندها
اعطونا حل وين المساعده وين
مساعدات بعمره ما راح تجي له
استطلاع الاوضاع الاغاثيه في عفرين بريف
حلب بينضم الينا محمد الجزائري محمد
السؤال المعتاد ما الذي وصل من المساعدات
حتى الان
نعم جلال نحن في هذه النقطه التي هي بين
مدينه اعزاز ومدينه بين مدينه جنديرس
ومدينه عفرين هذا ما وصل من المساعدات
الانسانيه بعض الخيام نشاهد هذه الخيام
هنا هذه النقطه تم انشاء فيها من قبل
المنظمات المحليه قرابه تسعين خيمه ولكن
هذه الخيام في كل خيمه منها يقيم عائلتان
او ثلاث ولكن هذه الخيام حقيقه هي غير
مجهزه داخليا اما بالبطانيات او بالفرش
ولكن ايضا هناك نقص ايضا في المدافئ فهذه
الخيم لا نظرنا الى كثير من الخيام لا
يوجد داخلها ايه مدافئ لتامين الدفع
للاهالي الاهالي يجلسون خارج الخيام في
اشعه الشمس علهم يحصلون على بعض من الدفء
ولكن الامكانيات ضعيفه من قبل المنظمات
انسانيه لم يكن هناك لم نشاهد الكثير من
المنظمات الانسانيه منذ الصباح اليوم وحتى
الان لم يكن هناك سوى بعض الفرق التي
تقدمت الى المنطقه وقامت ببعض الاحصائيات
ومن اخرجت حقيقه هذه الخيام التي عددها
تسعين خيمه تضم في كل خيمه ثلاث او اربع
عائلات ايضا هناك خارج الخيام عدد كبير من
الاهالي والعائلات تفترش الطرقات وتفترش
العراء تنتظر دورها بحصول على الخيام
نشاهدها في الجهه المقابله حقيقه الاعداد
والاهالي بالاضافه الى الاوضاع الانسانيه
الصعبه نحن هنا هذه احدى الخيام نستطيع
ممكن ندخل للخيمه
هذه الخيام التي نشاهدها التي يقيم فيها
الاهالي حاول ان الوصول الى داخلها
والصوره هنا هي ابرز
كل ما تحتوي هذه الخيمه بعض الفرش
والبطانيات تفتقر الى
المدفاه او التدفئه او بعض الوسائل
العوازل لحمايه الاهالي من البرد الشديد
حقيقه في الساعات الليل درجات الحراره
تشتد برودتها وتصعب الجلوس في هذه الخيام
كان فيها الخيام وخارجها نحن مسائل ليله
امس كنا هنا وكانت درجات الحراره شديده فش
البرد يعني لا يستطيع تحملها هؤلاء
الاطفال نشاهد هنا بالزاويه الاخرى
الاهالي الذين يفترشون الطرقات ينتظرون
دورهم بتقديم المساعدات ان كان خيام سالنا
الاهالي عن ابرز الاحتياجات التي
يحتاجونها قالوا لنا انها هي الخيام
بالاضافه الى تامين بعض الخدمات في هذا
المخيم من خزانات للمياه ودورات للمياه
بالاضافه الى الخيام والبطانيات وحليب
الاطفال نشاهدنا عدد كبير من الاطفال
والنساء هم كانوا ناجين من الزلزال ولكنهم
باتوا ضحايا نقص الامكاني الانسانيه وقله
المساعدات الانسانيه من قبل المنظمات ومن
قبل الفرق الانسانيه
حقيقه يتوافد بين الحين والاخر منظمات
انسانيه وفرق انسانيه وفرق تطوعيه تنظر
الى الواقع في المنطقه وتنظر الى واقع
الاهالي لتطلع عليه ومن ثم تسجل
احتياجاتهم لتحاول تامينها عن عبر
المنظمات وعبر المساعدات الامميه التي
تدخل بين الحين والاخر هذا جانب من
المعاناه هنا الذي في من المكان الذي يقف
به شكرا المعاناه الاخرى هي في مدينه
جنديرس التي تعتبر هي الاكثر تضررا هناك
اهالي ما زالت في المنطقه تنتظر ذويها
لدفنهم ومن ثم تبدا برحلتها بالبحث عن
ماوى شكرا محمد في عفرين بريف